[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de vip
aujourd'hui nous sommes en compagnie de
pejman memarzadeh violoncelliste de
formation chef d'orchestre et directeur
musical et artistique de l'orchestré de
l'alliance bonjour bonjour
alors comme je disais vous êtes le
directeur artistique de et musical de
l'orchestré de l'alliance quel est le
but de cet orchestre l'écouté depuis le
début c'était de fédérer les meilleurs
musiciens autour d'un projet à la fois
artistique mais également un projet qui
s'intègre réellement dans le monde
contemporain dans les préoccupations
sociales et qui également une fonction
de proximité vous avez fait un constat
avant de créer cet orchestre et qu'elle
était oui bien sûr vous savez moi je
suis d'origine iranienne je suis né en
iran je suis arrivé en france juste
avant la révolution et la question du
sens a été fondamental pour moi c'est à
dire le sens devenir un artiste est
également avoir un rôle dans la société
et avoir un engagement et donc dès le
départ c'était ce projet là donc il me
plaisait vraiment à la fois de fédérer
les talents pour pour cet orchestre et
un orchestre avec des talents
diversifiés ans qui rentrent de la
diversité des talents et la diversité
française aussi et puis mettre ses
talents au service d'un projet plus
large qui s'intègre vraiment aux
attentes et aux besoins de la société
il ya vraiment une volonté d'apporter la
musique classique dans des lieux qui en
sont assez éloignées vous avez des
programmes avec les collégiens avec des
élèves dans des conservatoires
il ya vraiment une volonté d'amener la
musique à auprès de la jeunesse
d'une part absolument près de la
jeunesse est vrai que depuis depuis que
nous sommes en résidence sur le
territoire des yvelines et bien c'est
plus de 16 mille jeunes qui ont pu
bénéficier de ces événements pédagogique
pensée pour eux soit à travers
effectivement des concerts pédagogiques
ont réuni les jeunes dans un lieu de
spectacle dans une salle de spectacle
soit quand ce n'est pas possible on en
voit effectivement les un quintette à
vent des solistes de l'ensemble un
quatuor à cordes pour aller à la
rencontre des jeunes dans leur
établissement et ça se passe comment des
établissements c'est un concert c'est
tout c'est un jour session souvent c'est
plusieurs sessions ça peut être deux ou
trois sessions dans la journée comme ça
on réunit des enfants dans une grande
salle un peu plus grande
ils sont en fonction sans une deux ou
trois classes en fonction de la salle
des
des salles disponibles et on les réunit
pour qu'ils puissent effectivement à la
fois s'émerveiller découvrir les
artistes répondre aux questions voilà
tout est question qui est que les
artistes puissent répondre à toutes
leurs questions notamment sur les modes
de vie comment ils vivent comme ils
gagnent leur vie
quelle place la musique a joué dans leur
vie voilà ça leur donne des perspectives
aussi de métier de professionnalisation
pourquoi pas la musique classique
aujourd'hui elle et elle est aimée par
les jeunes elle là il ya un intérêt
écoutez les jeunes c'est un des publics
je trouve les plus exigeants et les plus
difficiles on peut pas mentir à des
jeunes donc nous quand on arrive
effectivement à 9 heures du matin
effectivement par exemple à mantes la
jolie pour recevoir 300 jeunes on peut
pas mentir donc nous on sait faire cinq
heures du matin on arrive sur place ont
fait un petit rat corps est on est on
est comme si on se présenter à la salle
gaveau à la philharmonie de paris on est
avec le même degré d'exigence et ça les
jeunes on ne trompe pas avait là dessus
par-delà je dirais l'émotion en plus
l'exigence artistique le niveau qu'on en
compte on laissait enfin choc émotionnel
immédiatement les réveiller avec la
beauté des choses magnifiques dubé toque
du mozart du tchaïkovski du soulman du
brahms en voilà enfin il ordonne le
grand répertoire des extraits bien sûr
mais on choisit les heures pour que ce
soit pertinent avec leur sensibilité
leur capacité de concentration mais
surtout par delà ce message d'émotion
d'éveil de sensibilisation
systématiquement
je rappelle aux jeunes que la france est
une terre à la fois extraordinaire
d'accueil parce que il ya beaucoup de
jeunes issus de la diversité aussi sur
ces territoires et bien et comme je suis
je reprends également cette diversité là
je suis comme vous le savez je suis
d'origine iranienne
la france m'a donné tous les atouts pour
réussir et jordi écouter chacun d'entre
vous a un talent et donc profitent voilà
vous avez la chance
effectivement que le département des
yvelines et souhaité que leurs caisses
soit en résidence sur le territoire
on vient à votre rencontre on met un
orchestre professionnel devant vous le
matin au plus proche de vous chez vous
et tout ça effectivement pour que vous
rendiez compte des possibilités que vous
avez donc votre unique de voir ces de
déceler de découvrir votre talent et
vous en avez au moins vous avez
certainement des talents il y en a un
qui peut être potentiellement pourrait
être le terme sur lequel vous allez
pouvoir capitaliser pour construire une
belle vie une vie qui va permettre de
réussir votre vie
2-2 vous tirez vous vers le haut vous
votre entourage votre famille votre
conjoint votre conjointe vers lui au
plus tard donc c'est vraiment aussi un
message très forte d'intégration
d'encouragement de valorisation parce
que très souvent vous savez des gens qui
sont confrontés au doute et m'a
finalement il se met pas dans les
conditions du succès donc là que la
prise de confiance tout ça est très
important l'encouragement comportant et
c'est vrai que nous comme on n'est pas
non plus on vient en soutien des
merveilleux professeurs on n'est pas
dans le cadre scolaire
mais environ en relais et on a un outil
si vous voulez et exogènes qui permet de
reposer des bonnes questions aux jeunes
pour qu'ils se mobilisent aussi donc par
delà ce moment musical et bien ses
sermons coup ils peuvent poser des
questions par rapport à mm par rapport à
la reconstruction
qu'elle soit musicale ou autres et avec
les seniors alors jae-in parce que vous
vous intervenez aussi avec des seniors
en perte d'autonomie
qu'est ce que vous apportez vous à ce
public là ben alors là c'est autre chose
effectivement on intervient dans cadre
de la prévention à la perte de
l'autonomie
donc ça c'est très important parce
qu'effectivement on s'est rendu compte
que l' isolement et est un vecteur de
vieillissement prématuré un
effectivement qui est aussi en même en
termes de santé physique et mentale
c'est dire que donc nous on est là plus
tôt pour rappeler l'attachement je
dirais du territoire à ses aînés et de
leur proposer d'une autre manière
effective de participer à des
répétitions publiques ou des cessions ou
justement j'ai il participe réellement
je m'adresse à eux ils vont également
proposer question qui se poserait qui
n'ont jamais eu l'occasion peut être de
poser
eh bien ils pourront les pauses et donc
ça c'est effectivement en intègre sa
dans le cadre de nos programmes alors
par exemple si ça arrive
une matinée ont fait deux sessions
pédagogiques et bien l'après midi on
reçoit des personnes âgées
on est à leur disposition il est prévu
également que
occasionnellement faire partager un
repas avec eux voilà pour aussi par
exemple
après l'avènement cette session qui leur
est ouverte spécifiques et bien en pays
puissent échanger avec l'ensemble des
musiciens
bien sûr on va attendre que les
conditions sanitaires à nouveau le
permettre mais c'est prévu
vous avez une devise dans ce cadre je
cite donner à découvrir pour
s'émerveiller
qu'est ce que vous entendez par là
écoutez ça rejoint ce que je vous disais
tout à l'heure un finalement la
découverte de la beauté enfin pour moi
effectivement la corde de la musique
classique et sa beauté a été un choc
et ça transfigure m avis à donner un
nouveau sens à ma vie si je n'avais pas
fait si je n'avais pas eu ce choc
émotionnel je ne serais pas devenu
musicien et je suis convaincu qu'en fait
la beauté on peut se retrouver dans un
taudis on peut se retrouver même dans
une autre pièce fermée en prison mais si
tout d'un coup mettre de la musique
sublime dans un endroit où il n'y a pas
d'électricité par et être enfin voila si
on a la capacité agrexco batterie et
bientôt d'un coup ça transfigurer la
voir la musique dans la tête l'entendre
sa transfiguré ses rangs logo le monde
plus beau meilleur c'est sûr donc je
suis convaincu de la force ii de
conversion et d'adhésion de l'humanité à
la beauté et dans ce cadre du coup vous
avez créé la filière mobile qu'est ce
que sait de quoi il s'inspire avait
justement alors s inspire alors ça c'est
amusant même question elle s'inspire
puisque de mon expérience personnelle
aussi parce que à la fois vous savez on
a été quand on était bien plus jeune
était en résidence au théâtre de poissy
et d'ailleurs on a des gros projets avec
le talent de poissy à nouveau mais la
clef bêta de poisy une spécificité c'est
qu'elle a une conque acoustique en
question de bois et puis moi quand je
suis allé lors des différents voyages
vous j'ai organisé des voyages en iran
des voyages musicaux en iran notamment
en perce sur la grand-place issement il
ya dans le palais
aurélie fouquet sur la grande place
disent manquer la seconde plus grande
place du monde pendant longtemps c'était
la plus grande pour être place du monde
à 10 par an car il ya eu tianamen mn
après ensuite en chine
eh bien il ya un pas des anciens et il
ya un salon de musique avec des caissons
qui ont des formes de musique et ça m'a
inspiré beaucoup et donc comme on avait
ce projet avec les yvelines d'aller à la
rencontre des populations les plus
éloignés parfois de la culture que ce
soit effectivement dans la nature ou
pourquoi pas au pied de deux barres
d'immeubles ou de hlm est bien d'avoir
un équipement adapté qui permettent de
proposer une expérience de concert de
grande qualité tant pour les spectateurs
que pour les artistes donc en fait cette
filière mobile c'est la fusion de ces
deux de mes différentes expériences et
qu'on puisse effectivement proposé une
très belle expérience de concert donc
dans ces expériences que vous avez vécu
il ya notamment l'iran vous avez fait
une tournée en iran c'est important pour
vous de retourner en iran d'avoir un
lien oui absolument écoutez moi je suis
tout simplement vers s'effectuant par le
col le contexte qui est très important
on a grandi dans un contexte très tendu
aujourd'hui où certains alimente la
haine la violence et des tensions je ne
vais pas les citer tout le monde sait
bien qui je pense et on espère qu'on va
pour avoir une chambre un changement de
gouvernance dans beaucoup de pays et en
particulier le premier pays en termes de
puissance économique et militaire et il
est très important de travailler dans le
cadre du dialogue entre les
civilisations
c'est vraiment pour moi fondamental de
devrait parce qu'effectivement de
rappeler ce qui nous unit plutôt que
d'appuyer sur ce qui nous désuni donc
voilà la division arrange très peu de
personnes mais les enrichit largement et
l'union et bien arrange tout le monde et
on a tous besoin de ça pour que pour
essayer de construire un monde un peu
passif y est donc effectivement je suis
très attaché à le vrai modestement c'est
ce que j'ai fait à travers différents
tournées en iran avec leur caisse de
l'alliance mais également lorsque
j'étais invité à diriger l'orchestré
tonic de téhéran à plusieurs reprises où
j'ai pu faire chanter la chorale en
france est à nouveau depuis plus de 40
ans c'étaient des choses que très
émouvante pour moi très importante et
puis je pense qu'effectivement
la france a besoin de l'iran mais
l'iran a besoin de la france et
réciproquement de fait c'est pas les
mêmes besoins c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui on a mis au ban de la
lettre des nations l'iran parce
qu'effectivement il ya des parce qu'on a
un certain monsieur tron qui dirige les
états unis qui a décidé de mettre en le
mettre à la poubelle un accord qu'elle
nécessitait de dix ans de travail un
accord qui était pas si tu as pacifiant
qui permet effectivement de réintégrer
l'iran réintègre le concert des nations
et qu'effectivement que la population
iranienne comme la pollution
occidentales européennes françaises
puissent bénéficier de la reconstruction
ce pays c'était un formidable rêve j'ai
été invité par air france notamment pour
le voyage initial quand ils ont rouvert
la ligne j'étais invité avec les
différents que le medef quand ils font
partie des 120 grands patrons du medef
qui sont parties en iran comme artiste
invité et parce que tout le monde était
persuadé qu effectivement convaincu que
l'acteur culturel c'est fondamental
voilà dans la relation qui unit la
france et l'iran depuis des siècles
depuis avant le 14
donc vous voyez c'est pas dans ça date
pas d'hier dans un autre registre vous
avez développé les saisons de la
solidarité en 2005 qu'est ce que c'est
vous avez pu aider des associations
oui absolument écouter c'est une
certaine fierté avait aussi des cédants
de la solidarité c'est un doux rêve
c'est vraiment mettre la musique au
service de l'homme
et ça rejoint c'est un des axes encore
qui est cohérent par rapport à ce moment
un autre engagement qui toujours
toujours c'est l'engagement artistique
au plus haut niveau mais comment le
décliner pour le mettre au service de la
société
on n'est pas un orchestre simplement
caritatif ou solidaire au social
sociétal
on est avant tout un orchestre mais qui
se pose c'est est ce son là et avec
effectivement on a souhaité mettre la
beauté aussi au service des grands
combats qui nous affrontons
collectivement que soit l'environnement
la maladie l'éducation les drames comme
effectivement les tremblements de terre
en haïti
on a fait effectivement on a fait trente
trente sept concerts dans le cadre de
différentes grandes salles
essentiellement à salle gaveau mais
également la philharmonie de paris et on
a pu reverser plus de un million cent
mille euros à 37 associations
caritatives et humanitaires dont qu'on a
on en tire une certaine fierté puisque
c'est l'intégralité des recettes qui
était chaque fois inversée grâce à la
solidarité des artistes qui touche et
qui touche de son cachet solidaire et
également à des entreprises mécènes qui
finance le coût de l'opération
donc en fait voilà c'est une grande
chaîne de solidarité et l'intégralité
des billets vendus et remis à une
association
voilà c'est un beau projet on espère le
compte et que c'est pas favorables
aujourd'hui à la solidarité parce que la
plupart des entreprises et on les
comprend bien ce recours vie un peu sur
elle même parce qu'ils doivent sécuriser
leur business model entre guillemets un
leurre leur modèle économique par donc
on va parler français ce sera mieux
et c'est vrai que voilà on a des
partenaires fidèles on espère pouvoir
reprendre avec eux cet engagement
sociétal
on vous le souhaite en tout cas merci
beaucoup merci pagesjaunes est malade et
je rappelle que le prochain concert sera
à perray en yvelines le 13 novembre
absolument avec une chanteuse à
découvrir marie perbost vraiment
exceptionnel voile d'une pureté une voix
exceptionnelle pour moi c'est la future
grande diva française
elle vient de remporter en février
dernier les victoires de la musique dans
la catégorie révélation artiste lyrique
et voilà j'ai eu la plus de plaisir de
la découvrir à 4 ans déjà par ailleurs
donc j'ai souhaité vraiment halal
associés à cette résidence en yvelines
et je suis certain que les gens qui vont
l'entendre vont être bouleversées par là
la beauté de sa voix
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup de nous
avoir suivi on se retrouvera bientôt
dans un nouveau numéro du vide
bonne journée
[Musique]